the simple pleasures in life like
enjoying a sip of water breathing or
simply taking a leak are just some of
the sacrifices actors make to bring us
our favorite movies check out the crazy
things actors will put up with in order
to get the shot
number one cat prosthetics like cats are
evil you may be surprised to find out
that kitty cat paulie juice
transformation hermione went through in
harry potter wasn't cgi and it wasn't
even emma watson either turns out emma
had a horrible allergic reaction to the
glue they were using on her face so
stunt double flick miles filled in for
the scene the shot isn't entirely
without cgi though as the cat eyes were
created in post maybe the movie cats
could take a lesson or two from harry
potter in feline makeup number two as
opposed to non-axe is stint danger brett
beatty was more than just a stunt double
for rhys davies in lord of the rings
because as it turns out the actor was
allergic to his prosthetics and this one
time beady had to throw an axe he
accidentally nicked his eyebrow now
here's the freaky part because he was
wearing a prosthetic mask the blood
couldn't get out and actually started
building up under the mask and
eventually one of the eye bags which was
glued on ruptured and the blood started
spurting out despite how horrific the
whole event sounds apparently it looked
a lot worse than it was number three
stellan skarsgard found himself in a bit
of a sticky situation while filming dune
i did not want to drown in that black
goo that i was
was dipping into there his suit weighed
about 88 pounds which by the way is the
weight of a baby hippopotamus the exact
look the director was going for
skarsgard needed a cooling vest hooked
up inside the suit so he wouldn't have a
stroke and then they found the man was
too buoyant for the oil and they had to
stab holes in the suit so he would sink
number four just 10 minutes of yoga and
you'll be fine we've all been there
curled up in weird positions on our
computer chair watching youtube videos
for hours on end and waking up with a
crook in the neck in the morning selma
hayek experienced something similar
while filming eternals apparently it
gets tiring carrying all that extra
weight around on your head who would
have thought she's not one for
complaining though and she did love the
experience number five didn't anybody
teach johnny depp not to run with
scissors the suit he was wearing was
supposedly so hot and tight it actually
caused him to pass out from running
while there are lots of stories about
actors coming close to passing out this
is the first we've heard of it actually
happening he didn't tell anyone he was
experiencing any dizziness ahead of time
or we're sure they would have been there
with water number six do beasts sweat or
do they pant dan stevens who played the
beast in the live-action beauty and the
beast had to use stilts and wear a
muscle vest he also needed to wear a
cooling vest to keep him from
overheating and honestly the best part
of this story is the fact he had to eat
four whole roast dinners a day to stop
himself from wasting away funny this
reminds us of one of the songs from the
movies when i was a lad i ate four whole
roast dinners the craft table on that
set must have been amazing
number seven and we don't mean the
a-list actors
turns out christian bale could barely
breathe in his costume because when it
was cold the material would get tight on
his head it got so difficult to breathe
he recounts seeing stars and bale had a
thing or two to say to robert pattinson
who's taking up the character in 2022
telling him
just make sure you're going to be able
to relieve yourself honestly that's good
advice tom holland had the same struggle
why is nobody building a secret zipper
into these things number eight ruby rose
has a bit more than rosy cheeks after
her time in the mask she had a latex
allergy that only got worse throughout
filming her hives got so bad she decided
not to return for a second season for
ruby all she had to say was eventually i
took off the cowl at the end and my
whole face was hives my throat was all
messed up it was like it was out of a
scary movie maybe they could have recast
her as the polka dot man's sister or
something number nine listen to your
mother's advice
after months of wearing caked on makeup
and heavy prosthetics jessica chastain
found her skin stretched out and feared
she'd done permanent damage to it when
she finally took all that makeup off and
truly saw herself for the first time she
said she recounts looking 50 years old
for the record she's 44 years old right
now if you keep making that face long
enough we guess it really does get stuck
like that hopefully after a few weeks it
bounced back number 10 maybe in this
case
do let go in a weird twist of fate kate
winslet almost drowned while filming the
titanic she remembers running away from
a wave that crashed against a closed
gate her coat was snagged and she
suddenly found herself submerged in
water and she had to struggle to get
herself free all we can picture now is
jack saying never let go
from atop the floating door you're
welcome to steal this great fanfic idea
by the way number 11 we're pretty sure
that isn't how you kill a zombie the
life of an actor sounds glamorous in
theory but when you've got a 1am makeup
call for a 6am start it seems a little
less ideal army of the dad's richard
cetrone found himself in this situation
when he was playing zeus the zombie king
early mornings long days in a silicone
costume that didn't breathe filming in
albuquerque in 100 degree weather now we
can see what taika waititi was on about
in frigai albuquerque boiled turkey
staying hydrated is important to say the
least
number 12. surprisingly the cause isn't
your annoying little brother we're
getting wrapped
at 4 11 and i don't mean wrapped like
goodbye for the day this is us star
mandy moore had to deal with different
prosthetics depending on what age she
was playing in the show when she was
playing 68 year old rebecca she started
the makeup process by taking advil to
protect from the inevitable headache she
would endure while her hair was pinned
back
we feel you girl there's no better
feeling than removing a ponytail at the
end of the day number 13. girls just
want to have fun well boys do too
while tom holland is no stranger to
women's fashion he was not too happy
with needing to wear a thong under the
spidey suit this was not optional and
coming in second place for most
uncomfortable part of the suit has to be
holland drinking water through a straw
protruding out of the suit's eye number
14. washing off your makeup after a long
day is no joke er washing margot
robbie's makeup off during suicide squad
was a pain in the
little monster they set up a pop-up tent
inside an abandoned building stood her
in a kiddie pool and sprayed her down
with hudson sprayers we were relieved to
find out a hudson sprayer was not a fire
hose but it still sounds uncomfortable
number 15. that's not the way menthol's
supposed to be used joe kiri was a gooey
snotty-nosed mess during the filming of
stranger things in the scene where his
character was getting beat up he had a
sponge stuffed up his nose and menthol
blown into his eyes
not much acting is really necessary in a
scene where you're actually looking and
feeling like total garbage i was like
all swollen underneath the makeup number
16
it does not get worse than this
the final battle in twilight had
elizabeth reeser who played as may
cullen in a ton of pain normally snow in
the eye isn't painful but when you're
wearing contacts and that snow is
actually made out of paper it's bound to
hurt in a whole new way her eyelids
swelled up from it one of the worst
possible things we can imagine is paper
cuts in the eyes are your eyes itchy now
too let's move on 17. still better than
bad breath being cinderella seems like a
dream come true until you remember the
impossible beauty standards thrust upon
women in hollywood there were some news
reports that lily james's waist had been
digitally shrunk down in her ball gown
but nope lily was squeezed into a very
tiny corset she couldn't eat in costume
and so was just chugging back liquids
because it's all she could digest and
she had to take frequent breaks while
they filmed dance scenes because she
found herself breathless and not because
any prince was sweeping her off her feet
and her shoes they were made of real
swarovski crystals they were incredibly
painful and the actor couldn't even get
them on it doesn't fit
because it's made of frosty crystal
number 18. trust us complaining doesn't
get you
anywhere barry keon was a big complainer
about the three layers to his costume
especially when it came to the heat i
took three layers to it and i complained
every day about it while boiling alive
in a superhero suit isn't anything new
for actors we can definitely say we
empathize with him all the same it's
quite hard to move in number 19. we're
not talking about bearded dragons did
you hear about the real flaming beard
that was used in pirates of the
caribbean here comes the smolder actor
vince lozano was burned other people
were burned and the beard actually
caught on fire seriously this one should
have just been done with cgi number 20
for what was supposed to be a floating
scene she sure was weighed down a lot
she blows up like a balloon and floats
away and it's a lot easier to say that
than it is to do it pam ferris blowing
up like a balloon as ant marge in harry
potter wasn't cgi her inflatable suit
had three stages of prosthetics and
weighed about 50 pounds it contained
special pumps degassing chambers for
inflating and deflating the suit and
expandable rubber bladders seriously
they couldn't find better names for this
stuff the crazy part is the suit caused
her to faint while they were filming the
scene hey look we found a second fainter
do you have any other crazy stories of
actors putting themselves in danger for
a role leave them in the comments and
then go distract yourself from the
horrible the horrible thought of paper
getting stuck underneath your eyelid